récession moins forte que prévue en 2020
pourtant malgré ces mauvaises nouvelles
perspectives de rebond révisé à la
hausse par le fmi le ciel bleu ciel on
dirait pas semble s'éclaircir pour
l'économie française en ce début d'année
2021 à mesure que l'épidémie de kobe tu
se stabilise dans le monde mais derrière
les gros tickets les la réalité de cette
reprise en france comme d'ailleurs dans
le reste de l'europe est elle à la
mesure du redémarrage en trombe qui se
profile aux états unis après le
spectaculaire redressement va chine
c'est l'objet de notre édito échos ce
soir bonsoir j'accepte qu'il ya merci
d'être avec nous bonsoir c'est fanny
alors récession moins forte que prévu
le shop de l'épidémie aurait donc été
moins grave que ce qui avait été annoncé
jacques oui tout à fait les derniers
chiffres donnent une récession ou une
dépression de -28 3%
c'est effectivement nettement moins que
ce que les économistes estiment et
jusqu'à maintenant
bruno le maire a parlé de -10% moi même
j'avais avancé des chiffres qui avaient
jusqu à -11%
donc oui d'une certaine manière les
chiffres sont beaucoup moins mauvais que
ce qui était prévu
maintenant il faut tout de suite dire
que une dépression de -8 3% dans une
année c'est quelque chose absolument
sans précédent en france ce sont des
chiffres qui sont de l'ordre de ceux de
la crise de 1929 donc néanmoins le choc
économique sur la france a été un choc
majeur est par ailleurs il faut aussi
dire que les l'ensemble du contexte
économique qui entoure ces chiffres est
très loin d'être rassurant alors avant
d'aller plus loin dans l'analyse jacques
peut-on dire sur les chiffres de 2020
alors sur 2020 si vous voulez l'ensemble
de l'économie mondiale a connu
une dépression très nette une dépression
qui est en moyenne de - 3 et demi pour
cent donc on voit bien là que la france
se situe très en deçà en réalité de la
dépression mondiale
alors ce qu'on peut remarquer ces deux
choses premièrement le fait qu' il y a
deux zones qui ont été particulièrement
frappé la zone euro moins 7,2 pour cent
et l'amérique latine - 7,4 pour cent
ce sont des choses qui sont extrêmement
avancé quant au contraire les économies
émergentes d'asie n'ont connu une
récession que deux mois 1,1 pour cent
donc ça c'est déjà un premier problème
et puis la deuxième chose qu'il faut
dire que c'est que à l'évidence les
économies avancées des économies de
vieilles industrialisation en fait
eh bien ce sont les économies qui ont
connu des récessions qui sont très
largement supérieur à la moyenne
mondiale des récessions de l'ordre de -
5 % alors que la moyenne mondiale est à
-3 et demi pour cent alors on n'est que
de savoir ce qui s'est passé dans ces
pays
pour quelle raison justement que s'est
il passé
c'est là où il y a une des clauses très
intéressant parce que dans ces pays de
vieille industrialisation on voit qu'il
y a des différences assez importantes
entre pays par exemple d'abord il ya les
états unis alors les états unis ils ont
ils
ils ont moins souffert de la crise du
coc vite que les autres pays et surtout
aujourd'hui ils connaissent 1re
démarrage en fanfare de l'économie qu'il
s'agisse du redémarrage de la
consommation ont bien entendu une
consommation qui a été boostée par
l'échec qui ont été données à tous les
ménages américains mais aussi la très
bonne résistance des économies du
numérique des écrans géants du numérique
les gaffes acquis sont américains et
enfin quelques entend par là c'est que
c'est le rebond de l'industrie près
pétrolière après si on regarde justement
en europe on voit qu'il y a
deux phénomènes qui sont très nets
premier phénomène c'est que un pays
comme l'allemagne et auquel on peut
associer le japon qui était un pays
asiatique mais dont la structure
économique et industriel est assez
proche de la langue
ces pays ne résiste pas mal du tout
puisqu'ils sont autour de - 5 - 5 et 10%
par rapport à ces pays la france qu'on
associés d'ailleurs plutôt à ce type de
pays eh bien il se retrouve très décalé
et elle se retrouve elle plutôt au
niveau de pays comme l'italie l'espagne
voire le royaume uni qui conte connu des
des pressions extrêmement fortes
avec la crise sanitaire donc il ya aussi
une chose qui apparaît c'est aujourd'hui
une forme de divergences au sein des
pays industrialisés au sein et en
particulier des pays européens
on voit une divergence qui est en train
de s'ouvrir entre eux l'europe du nord
et l'europe du sud et la question cette
situation va-t-elle perdurer avec la
reprise
alors là tout est fini vous avez tout à
fait raison parce que là ce sont les
chiffres sur 2020 donc il faut peut être
regarder aujourd'hui ce qui va se passer
sur l'avenir est là quand on regarde les
prévisions qui sont faites par le fonds
monétaire international
ce sont des chiffres qui ont été publiés
à la fin du mois de janvier
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que les
économies européennes allemagne france
espagne italie sont plutôt au bas du
graphique
elles ne retrouveront leurs niveaux de
2018 qu'en 2022 pour l'allemagne la
france et l'espagne
probablement 2023 seulement pour
l'italie alors que au contraire et bien
la chine et les économies émergentes
d'asie
elle caracole en tête ce qui fait peser
le risque d'une forme de déclassement de
l'europe 1 par rapport au pays david
alors quand on est vous jacques par un
déclassement de l'europe
justement si vous voulez le fait que
l'europe les etats-unis aussi
représentés dans les années 1950 1960 le
coeur
de l'industrie le coeur de la croissance
en fait au niveau mondial et qu'est ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui eh bien on voit
que l'union européenne qui en 2002
faisait à peu près 20% du pig mondiale
bon alors en parité de pouvoir d'achat
eh bien il est tombé à 16 % en 2013 2014
et il tombera
si on en croit le fonds monétaire
international à 12% en 2022
par rapport à ça ce que l'on constate
aussi c'est l'explosion
littéralement des pays d'asie émergente
qui était à 17 % c'est-à-dire sous la
part de l'union européenne en 2002 qui
ont atteint grosso modo 30 % en 2013
2014 et qui depuis 2019 et là encore si
on croit les prévisions du fmi vont
continuer à avancer très fortement
puisqu'il devrait à pain en 2022 à peu
près 42 % du pib mondial
donc le déclassement c'est ça c'est le
fait que alors que l'union européenne et
les pays d'asie émergente faisait à peu
près jeu égal l'union européenne était
même au dessus des pays de l'asie
émergente en 2002 en 2022 donc vingt ans
après et bien l'union européenne ne
représentera plus que 30% de la part du
pib des pays d'asie émergents c'est cela
le déclassement alors jacquel peut-on
espérer que le plan de relance européen
permettra justement d'inverser cette
tendance
si vous voulez là encore il y aller il
ya ce qui est dit et puis il ya la
réalité un ce plan il a il faut le
rappeler il a été adopté à l'été dernier
donc à l'été 2020 il ne sera en réalité
mis en oeuvre qu'à l'été 2021 au mieux
je dis bien au mieux peut-être même ça
sera plutôt vers la fin de 2021 et alors
qu'est ce qu'il prévoit il prévoit
grosso modo 750 milliards d'euros
sur deux ans je dis bien sûr deux ans
alors que si on regarde les sommes qui
ont été dépensées en 2020 donc sur une
année les sommes budgétaires qui ont été
dépensés en 2020 pour sept pays
eh bien on voit que ces sept pays de
l'union européenne et sept pays
d'ailleurs de la zone euro eh bien ils
ont à eux c'est déjà dépensé plus de 760
milliards d'euros donc qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que un le plan
européen est très en deçà des besoins de
l'union européenne et de la zone euro
ces besoins ils ont d'ailleurs été
estimé par le parlement européen
autour de 2000 milliards d'envois qu on
en est très loin
deuxièmement à travers toute une série
d'astuces comptable sur les 750
milliards on sait très bien qu'il n'y
aura que 500 milliards d'argent frais et
donc qu'est ce qu'on se dit dans se dit
que de ce point de vue là le plan de
l'union européenne
il est très présente deux sens de ce
qu'il faudrait faire
si nous voulions réellement rattraper ou
moins stabilisé notre situation par
rapport aux pays d'asie
alors on se demande jacques où sont les
bonnes nouvelles alors y'a quand même
des bonnes nouvelles il faut le dire les
bonnes nouvelles
elles portent plutôt sur le passé oui
c'est vrai la crise de 2020 a été moins
grave que ce que l'on pouvait craint et
je répète avec moins vite moins 8,3 pour
cent même si c'est un chiffre assez
terrible en lui mais malgré tout c'est
mieux que ce que l'on pouvait craindre
encore au mois de novembre au mois de
décembre
c'est à dire des chiffres d'un moins dix
mois on se voit moins 12%
donc oui il y a une bonne nouvelle en ce
qui concerne le choc de 2020 mais quand
on regarde ce qui va se passer en 2021
et en 2022 en particulier avec la fin
progressive des aides qui vont d'une
certaine manière rêvée
les dégâts qui ont été faits dans
l'économie bien quand on se tourne vers
le futur eh bien on voit là que la
situation est extrêmement préoccupante
que l'union européenne est en train de
décrocher dans la compétition mondiale
rapport aux pays de l'asie émergente et
que nous en france nous sommes en
particulier tirée vers le bas par cette
situation de l'union européenne alors
que l'allemagne
s'il faut parler d'elle justement eh
bien elle est d'ores et déjà prête à ne
pas respecter toute une série de règles
de l'union européenne
elle est prête déjà à lancer ses propres
plans sans trop se soucier de ce qui
sera fait en europe et donc on peut
quand même un moment donné se poser la
question est ce qu'il ne serait pas tant
que la france élabore une politique
économique réellement nationale si elle
veut survivre dans les prochaines années
et merci jacques beaucoup de questions
merci pour cet éclairage édifiant à tout
point de vue est la semaine prochaine